One thing about living under a dictator, there's stuff you have to ignore or suffer the consequences. A decade ago in Egypt, you could get thrown in prison for suggesting publicly that the president was laying the groundwork for his own son to replace him someday, which, by the way, he was. When a member of the Egyptian parliament implied on television that the military might have been extensively involved in the assassination of former president Anwar Sadat--
在独裁统治下生活，有一件事你必须学会忽略，否则就会自食其果。十年前在埃及，如果你公开暗示总统正在为他儿子未来接班铺路——顺便说一句，他确实在这么做——你可能会被关进监狱。当一名埃及议会议员在电视上暗示，军方可能深度参与了前总统安瓦尔·萨达特的遇刺事件时——
He had his parliamentary immunity stripped the next day, a very fast military trial, and he went from being a member of parliament to being behind bars within about a week.
第二天他的议员豁免权就被剥夺了，经过一场极其迅速的军事审判，大约一周内，他就从一名议员沦为了阶下囚。
Michelle Dunne was a Mideast specialist at the State Department and the White House. She lived in Egypt. She speaks Arabic. She's now at the Carnegie Endowment for International Peace. She edits the Arab Reform Bulletin. She says that back when Hosni Mubarak was running Egypt, the way he used the intelligence services and security forces, everyone was forced to report on everyone else to the authorities. She knew whenever she would be with anybody in Egypt, the would get a phone call afterwards asking what the conversation was about.
米歇尔·邓恩曾是美国国务院和白宫的中东专家。她曾在埃及居住，会说阿拉伯语。她现在在卡内基国际和平基金会工作，负责编辑《阿拉伯改革公报》。她说，在胡斯尼·穆巴拉克统治埃及期间，由于他利用情报部门和安全部队的方式，每个人都被迫向当局举报他人。她知道，每当她在埃及与任何人在一起时，之后总会接到一个电话，询问那次谈话的内容。
And this happened to me. One time I was having dinner with a friend. And this was a person who was very active and very kind of pro-democracy and so forth. But that friend got a telephone call during the dinner. And it was clearly a telephone call that he could not put off-- that he had to take. And I heard him give a dump on a meeting that had taken place that afternoon-- not a meeting I had been at, but a meeting other people I knew had been at-- who was there, what did they say. And then afterwards, my friend said to me kind of apologetically, oh well, this is so and so. And I know he's from security, but he's really not a bad guy. He has good intentions. He's trying to help us out. So yeah, I do answer his questions when he calls.
这种事也发生在我身上。有一次我和一位朋友共进晚餐。那个人非常活跃，而且相当支持民主等等。但那位朋友在晚餐期间接到了一个电话。很明显，这是一个他无法推托、必须接听的电话。我听到他汇报了当天下午举行的一次会议——那不是我参加的会议，而是我认识的其他人的会议——谁出席了，他们说了什么。事后，我的朋友有些歉意地对我说，哦，那是某某人。我知道他是安全部门的，但他其实不是个坏人。他心地善良，是在试图帮助我们。所以，是的，当他打电话来时，我会回答他的问题。
That's changing now, she says. She was there last week and says Egyptians are starting to feel like they don't have to rat people out anymore. As the Arab Spring has reminded everybody and made abundantly clear, we Americans have been and still are allies with some terrible leaders, not just in Egypt but across the Mideast.
她说，现在情况正在改变。她上周去过那里，说埃及人开始觉得他们不再需要去举报别人了。正如“阿拉伯之春”提醒所有人并充分表明的那样，我们美国人过去一直是，现在依然是一些可怕领导人的盟友，不仅是在埃及，在整个中东都是如此。
It's This American Life , by the way, from WBEZ, Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
顺便说一下，这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由美国公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
We were putting together this week's program. And the theme of our program this week is "See No Evil"-- stories of people basically burying their heads in the sand in the face of wrongs being committed of various sorts. And we wondered about all those years that we were allies with Mubarak and all those other guys-- how much what we really pushing them to hold fair elections and respect human rights? And how much was our policy "see no evil?" Don't deal with it. Don't push.
我们正在制作本周的节目。本周节目的主题是“非礼勿视”——讲述人们在面对各种不公正时，基本上选择掩耳盗铃的故事。我们不禁怀疑，在过去那些年里，我们与穆巴拉克和其他那些家伙结盟时——我们究竟有多大程度上在推动他们举行公平选举和尊重人权？又有多少政策是“非礼勿视”？不去处理它，不去施压。
And so we called Michele Dunne because she had insider's knowledge. From 2000 to 2002, she was the US government official dealing with human rights questions in Egypt. She was the Human Rights Officer at the US Embassy in Cairo.
所以我们联系了米歇尔·邓恩，因为她有内幕知识。从2000年到2002年，她是美国政府处理埃及人权问题的官员。她是美国驻开罗大使馆的人权官员。
Well, I think the United States was bringing stuff up. But I would differentiate between raising human rights issues and really pursuing them seriously.
嗯，我认为美国确实提出过这些问题。但我会区分“提出人权问题”和“真正认真地追求人权”。
So, she says, usually there was no strategy to tie human rights changes that we wanted to see to things that the Egyptians wanted from us. Instead, she'd gather examples of people being jailed and treated unfairly. And she and the head of the Political Section at the US Embassy would then go in to discuss-- it was kind of a routine thing-- go in to discuss these with Egyptian officials.
所以她说，通常我们没有任何策略将我们希望看到的埃及人权变革与埃及人从我们这里寻求的东西挂钩。相反，她会收集人们被监禁和受到不公正待遇的案例。然后，她和美国大使馆政治部门的负责人会去讨论——这是一种例行公事——去和埃及官员讨论这些问题。
And I remember some meetings at the foreign ministry. There was a specific director for human rights in the foreign ministry. And that person was there to receive the complaints of foreigners about human rights. But the reply we would often get is, these are internal affairs. They're none of your business. We don't even know why you're bringing them up with us.
我记得在外交部开过几次会。外交部有一个专门负责外事的人权主任。那个人负责接待外国人对人权问题的投诉。但我们经常得到的回答是：这些是内政。与你们无关。我们甚至不明白你们为什么要跟我们提这些。
And how was that said? OK. So I'm picturing like you and the political officer. And I'm picturing some big office. And there's like-- are their snacks? Do they offer you water? Is there a little thing of dates?
那是怎么说的呢？好吧，我在想象你和政治官员的画面。我在想象一个大办公室。有没有零食？他们给你提供水吗？有盘枣子吗？
There's always tea or coffee. Yes. I don't remember snacks, but tea or coffee.
总是有茶或咖啡。是的。我不记得有零食，但有茶或咖啡。
And are you sitting on couches in some office or are you--
你们是坐在办公室的沙发上，还是……
Yes.
是的。
Yeah. And then is it the sort of thing like in a movie, where you go over like a list of things. And the foreign minister is silent, silent, silent. And then he says, well these are internal affairs. He's gives you like a one sentence answer. Is it a friendly kind of thing? Is it a pro forma thing?
是的。那这就像电影里那样吗？你们列出一系列事情。外交部长沉默，沉默，再沉默。然后他说，嗯，这些是内政。他只给你一句回复。这是一种友好的方式吗？还是一种走过场的方式？
It really depends on the meeting. And the kind of meeting that I'm discussing-- kind of a working level meeting with the person whose job it is to know about these things-- it would probably be a little bit friendlier. And they might say basically, these are not your affair. These are internal issues. But I would also like to let you know that these people are going to be treated fairly. So they would tell you first of all that you have no right to discuss those issues, but then they might proceed to actually discuss those issues with you.
这真的取决于会议的情况。我所说的这种会议——与负责这些事务的人员进行的工作层面的会议——可能会友好一些。他们可能会说，基本上，这些不是你们的事。这些是内部问题。但我也会让你知道，这些人会受到公正对待。所以他们会首先告诉你，你无权讨论这些问题，但随后他们可能会继续和你讨论这些问题。
President Bush, she says, did have a period of really pushing the Egyptian government on human rights. In 2002, President Bush withheld $133 million in aid because Mubarak's government had jailed a democracy advocate, Saad Ibrahim.
她说，布什总统确实有一段时间真的在人权问题上向埃及政府施压。2002年，布什总统扣留了1.33亿美元的援助，因为穆巴拉克政府监禁了一位民主倡导者，萨阿德·易卜拉欣。
And he wrote to Mubarak and told him specifically, because you are sending to prison people who are peaceful opponents of your government, I'm not going to give you this aid. That caused a great deal of unhappiness in Cairo. President Mubarak was furious about it.
他写信给穆巴拉克，明确告诉他：因为你把政府的和平反对者送进监狱，我就不会给你这笔援助。这在开罗引起了极大的不满。穆巴拉克总统为此非常愤怒。
But it worked. Ibraham finally was freed. President Bush pushed for freer elections and those happened in 2005. But after the election results put members of the Muslim Brotherhood into 20% of parliament seats, Mubarak cracked down and the Bush administration stopped pushing them so hard. Then when President Obama came in, he actually cut back-- he cut the funding by half for the remaining pro-democracy initiatives that the US still had going.
但这奏效了。易卜拉欣最终获释。布什总统推动了更自由的选举，这些选举在2005年举行了。但在选举结果显示穆斯林兄弟会成员占据了议会20%的席位后，穆巴拉克进行了镇压，布什政府也不再那么强硬地施压了。后来当奥巴马总统上台时，他实际上削减了资金——将美国仍在进行的剩余支持民主倡议的资金削减了一半。
So in the years where you were in Cairo and part of the government-- and now enough time has gone by and circumstances have changed enough, I hope that you can talk honestly about this-- did you feel like we were pushing the Egyptian government as much as could be pushed? In other words, as a human rights officer, did you feel like, OK, we're saying everything that can be said productively, and that's it? Or did you feel at the time, we could be doing a lot more for human rights? We could be pushing this regime more. We should be squeezing them more.
那么，在你身处开罗并作为政府一员的那些年里——现在时间已经过去足够久，情况也发生了足够大的变化，我希望你能诚实地谈谈——你是否觉得我们已经尽可能地向埃及政府施压了？换句话说，作为一名人权官员，你是否觉得，好吧，我们已经说完了所有能有成效的话，仅此而已？或者你当时觉得，我们本可以在人权方面做得更多？我们本可以向这个政权施加更大的压力。我们本应该施加更多压力的。
I felt the latter. I felt we could be doing more. And there was a lot of discussion about what we should say publicly, what senior officials should say-- whether it's the Secretary of State, or the President in some cases, or the US ambassador-- to put some pressure on. And the thing that I felt frustrated about is we were so careful about doing that-- there was always a lot of concern about rustling the government's feathers and so forth-- but I often felt concerned that we were just not making clear where the United States stood on these issues. That doesn't mean that once we say it, we have to make it happen and we have to sacrifice everything in the relationship to making it happen. But it frustrated me that we often weren't, I thought, signaling to the Egyptian people where the United States stood on these issues.
我感到后者。我觉得我们本可以做得更多。关于我们应该公开说些什么、高级官员——无论是国务卿、某些情况下的总统，还是美国大使——应该说些什么来施加压力，有过很多讨论。让我感到沮丧的是，我们在做这件事时太谨慎了——总是担心会惹恼政府等等——但我常常感到担忧的是，我们只是没有明确表明美国在这些问题上的立场。这并不意味着一旦我们说了，就必须让它实现，并不意味着我们必须为了实现目标而牺牲关系中的一切。但令我沮丧的是，我认为我们经常没有向埃及人民表明美国在这些问题上的立场。
And we've paid the price for that, she says. Because it just contributed to the feeling that the Egyptian people now have that we were not on their side.
她说，我们为此付出了代价。因为这助长了埃及人民现在的感觉，即我们并没有站在他们那一边。
Today on our show, we have three stories of people turning their backs, turning their heads, not dealing with wrongdoing, sometimes for very good reasons, sometimes for not such good reasons. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个关于人们背过身去、转过头去、不处理不法行为的故事，有时是因为很好的理由，有时是因为没那么好的理由。请留下来。
Act One, Blood Brothers. Let's start with a family story. In a family it can be hard getting everyone to admit and agree when something has gone wrong. Lisa Pollak has a very extreme example of that.
第一幕，血亲兄弟。让我们从一个家庭故事开始。在一个家庭里，要让每个人都承认并同意某件事出了问题是很困难的。丽莎·波拉克有一个非常极端的例子。
When Josh Martin was a kid, his mother asked him to promise something. If anything ever happens to me, she said, you need to look out for your brother Ben. The unusual thing about that request is that Ben was Josh's older brother, 10 years older. And Josh had thought it was Ben's job to look out for him. Since Josh's father was out of the picture, he relied on Ben as a substitute dad.
当乔什·马丁还是个孩子时，他的母亲让他许下一个承诺。她说，如果我发生什么事，你需要照顾好你的哥哥本。这个要求不同寻常之处在于，本是乔什的哥哥，大他10岁。乔什一直认为照顾他是本的工作。由于乔什的父亲不在身边，他一直把本当作代父。
But Ben had his problems. And as he got older, Josh saw those too. Ben had a learning disability and struggled in school. He'd spent time living in homeless shelters and went in and out of low wage jobs. "Be sure to study," Josh remembers his mother, Nancy, saying. "You don't want to end up like Ben."
但本有他自己的问题。随着年纪增长，乔什也看到了这些。本有学习障碍，在学校里很挣扎。他曾在无家可归者收容所生活过，打过各种低薪工作。乔什记得母亲南希说：“一定要努力学习，你可不想像本那样。”
Josh thought his mom was too hard on Ben. But Nancy wanted Ben to do better. One day after a fight with Ben, her frustration boiled over. She walked outside crying and confided in a neighbor that she worried what would become of her oldest son. The eerie thing about that conversation with her neighbor is that it turned out to be one of the last conversations Nancy Martin ever had. After that, Ben did need his brother's help, just like his mother thought he would. And for Josh, keeping his promise to his mother turned out to be more complicated than he'd ever imagined.
乔什觉得妈妈对本太苛刻了。但南希想让本做得更好。有一天，在与本吵架后，她的挫败感爆发了。她走出门外哭泣，并向邻居吐露，她担心自己的大儿子未来会怎样。关于那次与邻居的谈话，诡异的是，那竟成了南希·马丁生前的最后几次谈话之一。在那之后，本确实需要他弟弟的帮助，就像他母亲所预料的那样。而对乔什来说，履行对母亲的承诺比他想象的要复杂得多。
Nancy Martin was a college fund raiser. And five years ago, she went on a business trip and didn't come home. Her rental car was missing. She didn't answer her cell phone. After two weeks with no sign of her, her sons knew the situation was about as bad as it could possibly be. Only then, it got worse. The local news reported that police had a suspect.
南希·马丁是一名大学筹款员。五年前，她去出差，却再也没有回家。她的租车失踪了。她的手机没人接。两周过去后仍无踪迹，她的儿子们知道情况可能已经坏到了极点。而随后，情况变得更糟。当地新闻报道说，警方锁定了嫌疑人。
Investigators here in Pittman, New Jersey, have spent hours interrogating the last known person to have seen Nancy Martin alive. It's her oldest son.
新泽西州皮特曼的调查人员花了数小时审讯最后一个见过南希·马丁活着的人。那是她的长子。
Her oldest son, Ben. A week earlier, he'd reported his mother missing. Now he was suspected of causing her death. Not only was he the last person to see her, but their last conversation didn't end so well.
她的长子，本。一周前，他报告母亲失踪。现在他被怀疑导致了她的死亡。他不仅是最后一个见到她的人，而且他们最后一次谈话也不怎么愉快。
Ben Martin tells me he and his mother argued here two weeks ago over the condition of the house that she owns. The single mother of three allegedly said she was leaving for a hotel.
本·马丁告诉我，两周前他和母亲在这里因为她名下房子的状况发生了争吵。这位三个孩子的单亲妈妈据称当时说她要搬去酒店住。
They haven't even found our mother and there's a prosecutor assigned already. I mean, it's scary.
他们甚至还没找到我们的母亲，检察官就已经指派了。我是说，这太吓人了。
That's Josh, Ben's brother. Josh thought this was all a mistake. He knew his brother was innocent. And he worried that Ben-- who wanted to be so helpful to police that he'd given two taped statements without an attorney-- could end up in jail for a crime he didn't commit. Here's Ben.
那是乔什，本的弟弟。乔什认为这一切都是个误会。他知道他哥哥是无辜的。他很担心本——本因为太想配合警方，甚至在没有律师的情况下提供了两次录音陈述——可能会因自己没犯的罪行而入狱。这就是本。
Can you imagine that? Being told your mom might be dead, and then being accused of doing something to her.
你能想象吗？被告知你妈妈可能死了，然后被指控对她做了什么。
You had nothing with your mom's disappearance?
你母亲失踪与你无关？
No, no.
不，不。
It probably could change from hour to hour, what I thought or what my theory was of what had happened to my mom.
我对母亲身上发生的事情的想法或理论，可能每小时都在变。
Again, Josh.
乔什又说。
I thought she could have gotten drunk and thought she was OK to drive, and went to the liquor store and didn't make it back. Or she had gotten into a car wreck out in the Pine Barrens, or she had done some silly online date and it went bad. Anything but Ben. That was the last thing made any sense to me.
我曾想她可能喝醉了，以为自己可以开车，去了酒铺却没能回来。或者她在松林荒原出了车祸，或者她上网约会出了岔子。任何情况都行，只要不是本。那是最后一件我觉得合乎逻辑的事。
Ben was such a good guy. He was such a nice guy. There was just no way that he could do something that terrible.
本是个很好的人。他是个很好的人。他绝不可能做出那种可怕的事。
That's Stephanie Perot. She was Josh's girlfriend then. They're actually engaged now. They're a cute couple. He's super tall and boyish looking. She's pretty and petite. Back then, Stephanie and Josh lived near enough to Ben to see him most weekends, and Stephanie and Ben had gotten close. Josh and Ben had a third brother, Matthew Leschan, who lived in Illinois but was traveling to New Jersey so all three brothers could be together. But for now when it came to helping Ben, Josh and Stephanie were on their own.
那是斯蒂芬妮·佩罗。她是乔什当时的女友。他们现在实际上已经订婚了。他们是一对可爱的情侣。他超级高，看起来很孩子气。她漂亮娇小。当时，斯蒂芬妮和乔什住得离本很近，几乎每个周末都能见到他，斯蒂芬妮和本也很亲近。乔什和本还有一个兄弟，马修·莱尚，他住在伊利诺伊州，但正前往新泽西，以便三兄弟团聚。但目前在帮助本的问题上，乔什和斯蒂芬妮只能靠自己。
We thought maybe he was being abused by the police, that they were trying to get a confession out of him that wasn't true, that they were just pressuring him. And we just took Ben under our wing, wanted him to stay with us, wanted him to just be away from the cops. We just wanted to help him out because we really didn't think that he was guilty. And we really loved him home a lot.
我们以为也许是警察在虐待他，他们试图从他那里逼供出莫须有的罪名，他们只是在向他施压。我们只是把本接到我们这里，想让他住下，想让他远离警察。我们只是想帮他，因为我们真的不认为他是罪犯。我们真的很爱他。
It's true that Ben was the last person to see their mom. And it's true that their last meeting ended in a big fight. But that didn't seem suspicious to Josh and Stephanie at all.
本确实是最后一个见到他们母亲的人，而且他们最后一次见面确实以一场大吵结束。但这在乔什和斯蒂芬妮看来一点也不可疑。
On the first day of her business trip to New Jersey, Nancy had surprised Ben with an unannounced visit. The house in Pitman where Ben lived was actually Nancy's house. Ben was living there because she asked him to move and act as a caretaker for the place when she moved Illinois the year before. But basic life skills like cleaning were not Ben's strong suit. And on the day of Nancy's visit-- a surprise visit-- the house was a complete wreck-- bags worth of garbage all over the house, unwashed dishes that were growing mold, litter boxes that had gone so long without being cleaned that the cats-- there were six in the house-- weren't using them anymore. When their mother walked and saw all this, Ben told his brothers, she let him have it.
在新泽西出差的第一天，南希不打招呼地突袭检查本，给了他一个惊喜。本住的皮特曼的房子其实是南希的房子。本住在那儿是因为她去年搬到伊利诺伊州之前，要求他搬过去并担任房子的看管人。但打扫卫生等基本生活技能并不是本的强项。在南希那次不期而至的那天，房子简直是一团糟——到处都是垃圾袋，没洗的碗盘长满了霉菌，猫砂盆已经很久没清理，以至于家里的六只猫都不再用了。当他们的母亲走进去看到这一切时，本告诉他的兄弟们，她大发雷霆。
Here's Josh.
这是乔什。
She had came in, burst open the door and woke him up, and started just yelling about the house's condition. And just yelling and yelling. And then he said, you know, she had drank some beer and continued to yell. And then she tried to go to sleep for awhile and got up and said that the bed was disgusting and smelled like BO, packed her bags, and left.
她闯进来，推开门把他叫醒，开始对着房子的状况大吼大叫。一直吼，一直吼。然后他说，你知道，她喝了一些啤酒，继续吼。然后她试图去睡了一会儿，起来后说床很恶心，有体味，收拾好行李走了。
And that she left storming out, not saying where she was going, not taking her phone, apparently. She just left.
然后她冲了出去，没说要去哪，显然也没带手机。她就那么走了。
And that didn't sound so out of the norm to us, to me or Matt.
这在我们看来并不算反常，对我和马特来说都是。
That sounded really plausible. That's something she would do-- storm out. And we believed him.
这听起来很可信。这是她会做的事——冲出去。我们相信他。
Josh and Matt told me they were used to their mother's outbursts. Her mood swings were unpredictable, they said. And if something set her off, her tirades could get nasty, especially, Josh says, if she'd been drinking. It wasn't something most people in their lives knew about. In fact, a few outsiders had told them they don't believe it. And it's still painful for them to discuss.
乔什和马特告诉我，他们习惯了母亲的情绪爆发。他们说，她的情绪波动不可预测。如果有什么事惹恼了她，她的长篇大论可能会变得很恶毒，乔什说，尤其是如果她喝了酒的话。这并不是他们生活圈里大多数人都知道的事。事实上，有几个局外人曾告诉他们，他们不相信这一点。而且讨论这些对他们来说仍然很痛苦。
Their childhood memories include happy moments interspersed with harrowing ones, like the time Nancy ordered Ben to tie Matthew up to a chair with an electrical cord. Josh told me she'd kick them out of the house as punishment, forcing them to find their own places to stay. He remembers coming home and seeing Ben sleeping in the bushes, and having to sneak food out to him, knowing he'd get in trouble if he let him in. Of the three sons, Ben always got it the worst.
他们的童年记忆中穿插着快乐时刻和令人痛苦的时刻，比如有一次南希命令本用电线把马修绑在椅子上。乔什告诉我，她会把他们赶出家门作为惩罚，强迫他们自己找地方住。他记得回家时看到本睡在灌木丛里，不得不偷偷带食物给他，因为知道如果让他进去自己也会惹上麻烦。在三个儿子中，本总是受气最重的。
Ben reported his mother missing on March 19, 2006. A couple days later, two detectives went to the house in Pitman-- Robert Hemphill and his colleague, Greg Owens.
本于2006年3月19日报告母亲失踪。几天后，两名侦探去了皮特曼的房子——罗伯特·亨菲尔和他的同事格雷格·欧文斯。
The very first time him and I went and talked to Ben, we were hoping she's going to be found and he had nothing to do with it. It wasn't until after we walked out the door, like with the neighbor and stuff, is when it started leading back to him.
当他和第一次去和本交谈时，我们希望她能被找到，而他与此无关。直到我们走出门口，和邻居谈过后，线索才开始指向他。
The neighbors across the street corroborated part of Ben's story-- that Nancy had come to visit. One of them had even talked to her outside and heard about the messy house and how upset Nancy was. But something worried the neighbors. They thought Nancy said she'd be in town all week. But they hadn't seen her, even though they'd seen her grey rental car in the driveway-- the same grey rental car that Ben said she'd left in. When detective Owens heard that, he knew there was a problem.
街对面的邻居证实了本部分的故事——南希确实来过。其中一个甚至在外面和她聊过，听到了关于凌乱的房子以及南希有多生气的事。但邻居有些担心。他们以为南希说她会在城里待一周。但他们没见过她，尽管他们看到她的灰色租车还在车道上——也就是本说她开走的那辆灰色租车。当欧文斯侦探听到这个消息时，他知道出问题了。
The neighbor had seen the rental car two or three days after Ben's version that they got in an argument, she jumped in it and left. And he remembered it very clearly, because I believe it had Virginia tags.
在他们争吵并开车离开的那个版本之后，邻居又看到了那辆租车两三天。他记得非常清楚，因为我相信那车挂着弗吉尼亚州的牌照。
You can probably see where this is going. That night, after cops had talked with the neighbors, the grey rental car with Virginia plates was found in a strip mall parking lot about five miles from Pitman. There was no sign in the car of Nancy Martin, her luggage, or computer. But there were traces of blood on the bumper and trunk. While police searched his house for evidence, Ben went to the library and emailed his brother Josh. Police believe mom is dead, Ben wrote. They also think I did something to her.
你大概能猜到接下来会怎样。那天晚上，在警察与邻居谈话后，那辆挂着弗吉尼亚牌照的灰色租车在距离皮特曼约五英里的一个购物中心停车场被发现。车内没有任何南希·马丁的行李或电脑的踪迹。但在保险杠和后备箱上有血迹。当警方搜查他的房子寻找证据时，本去了图书馆并给弟弟乔什发了电子邮件。“警察认为妈妈死了，”本写道，“他们也认为是我杀了她。”
By now, Ben was staying at Josh and Stephanie's apartment. Josh and Ben's brother Matthew was there now too, along with his wife. Her name's also Stephanie. Josh and his brother Matt were in a weird situation. They were the sons of the victim, so they desperately wanted police to solve the case. But they were the brothers of the suspect, so they wanted police to back off. The day after Josh and Ben were on that TV news story saying that police were wrong, investigators asked all of them except Ben to come in and talk. When they arrived, the mood was tense. Here's detective Hemphill.
此时，本正待在乔什和斯蒂芬妮的公寓里。乔什和本的兄弟马修现在也到了，还有他的妻子。她的名字也叫斯蒂芬妮。乔什和他的兄弟马特处于一个奇怪的境地。他们是受害者的儿子，所以他们迫切希望警察能破案。但他们又是嫌疑人的兄弟，所以他们想让警察退后。在乔什和本上了那个电视新闻故事，声称警察搞错了之后，调查人员要求除了本之外的所有人去谈话。当他们到达时，气氛很紧张。这是亨菲尔侦探。
They were upset. They were hurt. They were in disbelief. They were upset at us because they thought, hey, why aren't you guys-- you were talking here today on Sunday-- why aren't you out looking for my mother? And that was said to us. Why has the focus only been on our brother?
他们很沮丧。他们受到了伤害。他们不相信。他们对我们很生气，因为他们想，嘿，为什么你们不——你们今天周日在这说话——你们为什么不出去找我母亲？这话就是对我们说的。为什么焦点只在我们兄弟身上？
They kept going on and on. The detective and his assistant just kept telling us, no, he did this. We know he did this. What is it going to take for you to believe that he did this? And we told them they were being lazy and that all they wanted to do was just close the case and not have to worry about searching for her.
他们喋喋不休。侦探和他的助手只是不断告诉我们，不，他做了这件事。我们知道他做了。要怎样才能让你们相信是他做的？我们告诉他们，他们很懒，他们只是想结案，不用费心去寻找她。
Matt was angry too.
马特也很生气。
The question that was posed to me was that, what would it take for you to believe that Ben had something to do with your mom's disappearance? And I want evidence. I want evidence you're going to use in court to try to convict him. I want to see evidence.
向我提出的问题是，要怎样才能让你相信本和你母亲的失踪有关？我想要证据。我想要你们将在法庭上用来试图给他定罪的证据。我想要看到证据。
That afternoon they saw the evidence. Detectives took out pictures of the crime scene showing blood in the house and in the garage, as if a body had been dragged there. Ben himself had said no one had been in the house but him.
那天下午他们看到了证据。侦探们拿出犯罪现场的照片，显示房子和车库里有血迹，就像一具尸体被拖在那里一样。本自己曾说除了他没有人进过那栋房子。
And there was other evidence, including a surveillance tape showing Ben after he'd abandoned the rental car, wearing a shirt that had been found in the house with blood on it. At this point, the only thing the homicide case didn't have was a body. They were still searching, the detective said. But they were confident that Ben knew where his mother was.
还有其他证据，包括一段监视录像，显示本在弃车后，穿着一件在房子里发现的有血迹的衬衫。此时，凶杀案唯一缺少的就是尸体。侦探说他们仍在搜寻。但他们确信本知道他母亲在哪里。
Ben didn't come to the meeting, but he'd driven there with his brothers. When it ended, he was still in the car, where he'd been waiting the whole time.
本没有来参加会议，但他开车带着兄弟们去了。当会议结束时，他还在车里，他在那里等了整个过程。
Again, Josh.
乔什又说。
We got in the car and didn't say much to Ben. Didn't say a word. Just were still digesting what just happened. And he said something along the lines of, "You guys OK? What's the matter? You guys upset? What did they say to you? What did they say to you?" And we just-- Ben, not right now.
我们上了车，没对本说什么。一个字也没说。只是还在消化刚刚发生的事情。他说了一些类似的话，“你们还好吗？怎么了？你们生气了吗？他们对你们说了什么？他们对你们说了什么？”我们只是——本，现在不行。
And every time Ben asked, we were like just-- nothing. And we were kind of mean about it. We were like just stop. Like, shush. We'll talk about it later.
每次本问，我们就像——什么都没有。我们对此表现得很刻薄。我们就像说停下。嘘。我们以后再谈。
The detectives say they didn't want the family to interrogate Ben-- didn't tell them to do anything, really, other than if Ben said something, they needed to call.
侦探们说他们不想让家人审问本——除了告诉他们如果本说了什么就需要打电话之外，真的没让他们做任何事。
But Ben didn't say anything. Stephanie told Josh that they needed to confront Ben. But Josh refused. They argued about it. Josh wasn't saying that Ben was innocent anymore. He was saying things like, if we talk to Ben and he says he did it, it's over, Steph. You understand that? Over, gone. He told me he felt like a little kid putting his hands over his ears to block everything out.
但本什么也没说。斯蒂芬妮告诉乔什，他们需要和本对质。但乔什拒绝了。他们为此争吵。乔什不再说本是无辜的。他说了一些类似的话，“如果我们和本谈话，而他说他做了，那就完了，斯蒂芬妮。你明白吗？完了，一切都结束了。”他告诉我，他感觉像个捂住耳朵不想听任何东西的小孩子。
And for a few days it worked, though these are days that Josh barely remembers now. They drank a lot, he knows that. And though none of them really talked about it, Josh feels like he, Matt, and Ben were using the time to say goodbye. On what ended up being their last night together, the brothers and the two Stephanies drove to Philadelphia and spent hours just hanging out together. They went to Chinatown and drank, and took a long walk to the city's waterfront. They smoked and looked out at the lights until it was too cold to stay outside anymore. That night, at Josh and Stephanie's apartment, Ben shook and cried in his sleep.
这招奏效了几天，尽管这些天乔什现在几乎记不起来了。他知道他们喝了很多酒。虽然他们都没真的谈论这件事，但乔什觉得他和马特、本利用这段时间在告别。在他们相处的最后一个晚上，三兄弟和两个斯蒂芬妮开车去费城，花了几小时在一起。他们去了唐人街，喝酒，然后在城市的滨水区长途散步。他们抽烟，望着灯光，直到外面冷得无法再待下去。那天晚上，在乔什和斯蒂芬妮的公寓里，本在睡梦中颤抖并哭泣。
The next day, three days after they'd seen the evidence, Stephanie tell Josh it was over. She didn't give him a choice. We're going to sit Ben down and talk to him, she said.
第二天，在他们看到证据的三天后，斯蒂芬妮告诉乔什，一切都结束了。她没给他选择。她说：“我们要让本坐下，和他谈谈。”
I don't think I was ever mad at Josh. I just wanted him to wake up. And I think I was just hurting for him, but I wanted it to be over. And the only way it's over is if he says what happened. Come on. Let's get this over with. Talk to Ben.
我不认为我曾生乔什的气。我只是想让他醒过来。我想我只是为他感到难过，但我希望这件事结束。而结束的唯一方法就是他说出发生了什么。来吧。让我们搞定这件事。和本谈谈。
Ben sat on the couch and Stephanie kneeled in front of him. She put her hands on his knees. She was only 20 then. She didn't have any training for this.
本坐在沙发上，斯蒂芬妮跪在他面前。她把手放在他的膝盖上。她当时才20岁。她没有任何相关训练。
I just told him, "What happened? Just tell us what happened. We're not going to be mad at you. We just need to know." That's all that we could say to him. And he kept saying, "I don't remember. I don't remember." So I told him to close his eyes.
我只是告诉他，“发生了什么？告诉我们发生了什么。我们不会生你的气。我们只是需要知道。”那是我们能对他说的全部。他一直说，“我不记得了。我不记得了。”所以我让他闭上眼睛。
And then, almost as if she were talking to a child, she walked Ben through the story of the fight. Nancy comes in the house, she said. What happens?
然后，就像在和一个孩子说话一样，她引导本重现了那场争吵。她说，南希走进屋子，发生了什么？
And he has his eyes closed. And he goes, "She gets very upset. She's getting very mad. The house is a mess." And I say, "When she gets mad, how are you feeling?" And he says, "I start to feel overwhelmed. She's spitting in my face." Which she did. When she got very mad, she got close to your face, and literally you could feel the spit coming into his face, is what he said.
他闭着眼睛，说：“她变得很心烦。她变得很生气。屋子一团糟。”我说，“当她生气时，你感觉如何？”他说，“我开始感到不知所措。她在我脸上吐唾沫。”她确实这样做过。当她非常生气时，她会靠近你的脸，他说，字面意义上你能感觉到唾沫溅在他脸上。
Josh and Matt and his wife Stephanie were sitting there, just listening. What did Nancy say to you next, Stephanie asked?
乔什、马特和马特的妻子斯蒂芬妮坐在那里，只是听着。斯蒂芬妮问，南希接下来对你说了什么？
And he says, she tells me that I am worthless, that I should never have been born, that I'm a terrible son, that I can't keep anything clean, that this house is a [BLEEP] mess. He just went on about how upset she was and how she was screaming at him. And I say, "OK, well, what did she do next? And what did you do? Where were you standing?" And he says, "We're standing in the living room, by the door at this point. And she starts to push me." And I say, "What do you do when she pushes you?" And he says, "I start pushing her back."
他说，她告诉我我是个废物，我不该出生，我是个糟糕的儿子，我什么都清理不干净，这房子乱得像坨屎。他继续描述她有多生气，以及她是如何对他尖叫的。我说，“好吧，她接下来做了什么？你做了什么？你站在哪？”他说，“当时我们站在客厅，靠近门口。她开始推我。”我说，“当她推你时，你做了什么？”他说，“我开始把她推回去。”
It was the first time that Ben ever admitted the fight got physical.
这是本第一次承认争吵发生了身体冲突。
I'm like, "And then what happens?" He's like, "She started getting me into a headlock." And I said, "What happened when she got you into a headlock?" And he says, "I had to push her down onto the ground." And I said, "What happened after she was on the ground?" And he says, "I had to hold her down." But he says, "I had to put my hands on her neck, and I didn't let go until she stopped moving."
我说，“然后发生了什么？”他说，“她开始勒住我的脖子。”我说，“当她勒住你时发生了什么？”他说，“我不得不把她推倒在地。”我说，“她倒地后发生了什么？”他说，“我不得不把她按住。”但他又说，“我不得不把手放在她的脖子上，直到她不再动弹我才松手。”
Stephanie went outside and called the police. Later, after Ben's arrest, after he directed a caravan of police cars to the vacant farmhouse where he'd dumped Nancy's body, after he'd cried and said he was sorry and was taken to jail, Detective Hemphill told Stephanie-- and he meant it as a compliment-- that they couldn't have done it without her.
斯蒂芬妮跑出去报了警。后来，在本被捕后，在他带领一队警车前往他弃尸的废弃农场后，在他哭泣说自己很抱歉并被带进监狱后，亨菲尔侦探告诉斯蒂芬妮——他是真心地赞美她——说如果没有她，他们做不到。
And when he said that, I felt horrible. Because I said-- I was thinking, well that sucks, because I got him in jail. And he said, "You ever think about a law enforcement job? I think you really should consider going into that field. You're really good at it." And I just kept remember thinking I hated hearing that, because I got him in trouble. And I didn't want to get him in trouble.
当他说这话时，我觉得很糟糕。因为我想，那太糟了，因为是我把他送进监狱的。他说，“你想过从事执法工作吗？我认为你应该考虑进入那个领域。你真的很擅长。”我只是不断记得自己讨厌听到这些，因为我让他陷入了麻烦。我不想让他陷入麻烦。
He was just a good guy. And I know it sounds really, really weird to hear that, but he was a really-- Ben was a good guy. I don't know what happened or why he would do something that bad.
他只是个好人。我知道听起来很奇怪，但他是……本真的是个好人。我不知道发生了什么，或者为什么他会做那么坏的事。
Well, did you guys have a chance to ask him that?
那么，你们有机会问过他吗？
All he said that is just that he snapped. That he couldn't take it anymore because she kept telling him that he was worthless, and a terrible son. And saying very nasty things that he couldn't take anymore, he'd heard his whole life. But 30 years later, she was still saying the same thing, that she wishes he was never born.
他只说他失控了。他无法再忍受了，因为她一直告诉他他是个废物，是个糟糕的儿子。她说了一些他再也无法忍受的恶毒的话，他这一生都听着这些。但30年后，她仍然在说同样的话，说她希望他从未出生。
When you heard that, did you feel angry at her at all?
当你听到这些时，你对她感到生气吗？
Very.
非常生气。
Oh yeah, we were.
哦，是的，我们确实很生气。
Very mad at her.
非常生她的气。
And we knew he wasn't lying. Because these were things he had heard his whole life.
我们知道他没撒谎。因为这些是他一生中都在听的话。
Yeah, she really-- she could get very, very nasty. And we felt like she pushed him to do this. And that how dare she say these things and expect nothing to happen after that? It probably took like a good year before we actually started being mad at him and not her.
是的，她真的……她可以变得非常、非常恶毒。我们觉得是她逼他这样做的。她怎么敢说这些话，还指望在那之后什么都不会发生？可能花了一年时间，我们才开始真正生他的气，而不是生她的气。
After Ben's arrest, the one thing that didn't change was his brothers wanting to help him. Their goal now was to keep Ben from spending the rest of his life in prison. Using their mother's life insurance money, they hired a defense attorney, and told the court about how their mother had treated Ben. When Ben pleaded guilty to a reduced charge of aggravated manslaughter, the state asked for the maximum sentence, 30 years. At the sentencing hearing, the prosecutor described the gruesome details of Ben's crime, including the fact that he'd kept Nancy's dead body in the house for days before dumping it. In the end, saying he was giving slight to moderate weight to the reports of abuse, the judge sentenced Benjamin Martin to 15 years in prison.
在本被捕后，唯一没变的是他的兄弟们想帮他。他们的目标现在是让本不至于在监狱里度过余生。利用他们母亲的寿险赔偿金，他们聘请了一名辩护律师，并向法庭讲述了他们母亲是如何对待本的。当本对减轻的过失杀人罪表示认罪时，州方要求判处最高刑期，即30年。在量刑听证会上，检察官描述了本犯罪的骇人细节，包括他在丢弃南希尸体前将她的尸体留在屋内数天的事实。最终，法官表示对虐待报告给予轻微到中等的权重，判处本杰明·马丁15年监禁。
About a year after Nancy's death, like Stephanie mentioned earlier, something shifted for her and Josh. Their anger at Nancy began to fade. And their memories of her-- the good ones-- flooded back. Josh started having this recurring dream where his mom came home and everything was fine. He'd be so happy, and he'd wake up crying.
在南希去世大约一年后，正如斯蒂芬妮之前提到的，她和乔什身上发生了一些转变。他们对南希的愤怒开始消退。而他们对她的记忆——那些美好的——又涌了回来。乔什开始做这个反复出现的梦，梦见妈妈回家了，一切都很好。他会很高兴，然后哭着醒来。
It doesn't even need to be a dream. It can be something silly. Like we're watching TV and-- or I watch Say Yes to the Dress , because we're trying to get married and I like to look at the dresses and stuff. And it's little things like that. His mom, she would be here, and she'd help me go shopping for a wedding dress. And that's little things that'll make Josh melt down randomly. Just complete meltdowns, as in crying, sobbing, I miss my mom, I hate Ben.
甚至不需要是梦。可以是某种愚蠢的事。比如我们在看电视，或者我看《说 yes 到婚纱》，因为我们正试图结婚，我喜欢看婚纱之类的。就是这样的小事。如果他妈妈在这里，她会帮我挑婚纱。就是这些小事会让乔什随机崩溃。彻底的崩溃，哭泣、啜泣，我想妈妈，我恨本。
And then the next day, it's OK. And hi, we'll talk to Ben on the phone. And not tell him-- we never tell him about how sad he makes us. And we don't tell him that, because we feel like he's already sad enough himself. And he already has enough guilt on his shoulders that we really don't need to add on to it.
第二天又好了。嗨，我们会和本通电话。永远不告诉他，我们从不告诉他他让我们有多难过。我们不告诉他，因为我们觉得他自己已经足够难过了。他肩上的罪恶感已经足够重了，我们真的没必要再添砖加瓦。
But every once in awhile, they can't help it. Like this one day when Ben called from prison and Josh was in a bad mood.
但偶尔，他们也忍不住。就像有一天本从监狱打来电话，而乔什心情不好。
And I don't know why he picked up, but he did. And it--
我不知道他为什么要接，但他接了。它……
It was something Ben said to--
那是本说的一些话……
Because Ben kept going on--
因为本一直喋喋不休……
--tick me off.
——惹恼了我。
--in his letters about how-- just normal little things. And, I need a TV. And maybe you guys can send me money for this, and maybe you guys can send me money for that. And we're like, are you kidding? Are you really serious? He wants us to send him money? And that was when Josh was like, does he realize what he did to us? He's in there asking us for a radio? And I think that's-- he lost it. He was just like, Ben, you do realize you're in jail for good reason, right? You're not just in jail because you accidentally got put there. I mean, you killed my mom.
——在他的信里说关于那些……只是正常的小事。我需要一台电视。也许你们可以给我寄钱买这个，也许你们可以给我寄钱买那个。我们就像，你是认真的吗？你真的在开玩笑吗？他想要我们寄钱给他？那就是乔什爆发的时候。他就像，本，你意识到你因为正当理由在监狱里了吗？你不是因为不小心被放进去的。我是说，你杀了我妈。
So after you said that, did you feel better having yelled at him a little?
所以说了那些之后，你觉得对他大喊大叫之后感觉好点了吗？
No. I think I felt good doing it at the time. But maybe a few minutes later, I felt a little guilty. It's a weird feeling to not want to hurt the feelings of the person that killed your mom and wanting to kind of lay it on him at the same time. And I think he might be getting some confusing messages between me being mad at him and me supporting him.
没有。我想当时我这么做觉得很好。但几分钟后，我感到有点内疚。这是一种奇怪的感觉，既不想伤害那个杀了我妈的人的感情，同时又想对他发火。我想他可能在感到困惑，不知道我是在生他的气还是在支持他。
It seems like in some ways you have to willfully put it out your mind, what he did, in order to have him in your life.
似乎在某种程度上，为了让他出现在你的生活中，你必须刻意不去想他所做的事。
I think you're really right. Just, when we talk to him, we can't think about all the details of what happened. We have to just somehow block that out. Because there's no way to talk to somebody when you think, oh, and you left her there for four days. To me that's one of the most disturbing parts, is just to have a dead body in your house for four days. That seems just, it's disturbing. It's disgusting. It's horrible. It's all the evil words you can think of. What he did was wrong. But we want to talk to him.
我想你是对的。当我们和他交谈时，我们不能去想发生的所有细节。我们必须以某种方式阻断它。因为当你想到，“哦，你把她留在那里四天，”你就不可能和某人交谈。对我来说，那是其中最令人不安的部分，就是把一具尸体留在家里四天。那看起来……这令人不安。太恶心了。太可怕了。这是你能想到的所有邪恶词汇。他做的是错的。但我们想和他交谈。
The more we talk to you, the more we realize we're really confused. And we didn't realize how five years down the line, we're still completely messed up in our heads of how we feel. And that makes me sad. Because I thought we had it figured out. And I'm not mad at you for talking to us. I just, I can't believe that we still don't understand whether we hate Ben, we like Ben, we hate Nancy, we like Nancy. We can't figure that out. And it's been so long. We really should be able to pin that down. We can't. We've seen shrinks. We've done all sorts of helpful things. And we still are sitting here like, I don't know-- why we can be angry at her and love her. It's just so confusing. And it hurts.
我们和你交谈得越多，就越意识到我们真的很困惑。我们没意识到五年过去了，我们的头脑里对于自己的感受仍然完全是一团糟。这让我很难过。因为我以为我们已经想通了。我没因为你和我们交谈而生你的气。我只是……我不敢相信我们仍然不明白自己是恨本、喜欢本，还是恨南希、喜欢南希。我们想不通。时间已经过去了这么久。我们真的应该能弄清楚这一点。但我们做不到。我们看过心理医生。我们做过各种有帮助的事情。但我们仍然坐在那里，我想不知道——为什么我们能生她的气又爱她。这太令人困惑了。而且很痛。
Hello. Go ahead, we're all here.
你好。请继续，我们都在这儿。
In a small way, I recently got a sense of how confusing this all is. A few months ago, Matt's daughter Hannah turned six. And on her birthday, she got a call from her uncle Ben.
在很小的程度上，我最近感受到这一切有多么令人困惑。几个月前，马特的女儿汉娜六岁了。在她生日那天，她接到了她本叔叔的电话。
Hi, Ben.
嗨，本。
[SINGING] Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday, dear Hannah. Happy birthday to you.
[唱歌] 祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝亲爱的汉娜生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
Oh, you're very welcome. You having a good one so far?
哦，不客气。你目前过得愉快吗？
Josh and Stephanie have a daughter too. Their baby's name is Isabel, and she'll be one in June. So now there are two little girls who one day will have to learn that the Uncle Ben who calls and sings on their birthday, is the same Uncle Ben who's in prison for killing their grandmother. And two sets of parents who know that one day, they'll have to explain all of this. They just hope that when the time comes to do it, they'll have figured out how.
乔什和斯蒂芬妮也有一个女儿。他们的宝宝叫伊莎贝尔，六月份就一岁了。所以现在有两个小女孩，总有一天她们会知道那个在电话里为她们唱生日歌的本叔叔，就是那个因为杀害她们祖母而在监狱里的本叔叔。还有两对父母知道，总有一天，他们得解释这一切。他们只是希望当那一刻到来时，他们已经想好了怎么解释。
I love you, Ben.
我爱你，本。
I love you too Hannah. You take care now.
我也爱你，汉娜。你自己保重。
Lisa Pollak is one of the producers of our show.
丽莎·波拉克是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, pretending that everything is fine, just fine. Nothing unusual going on here-- while the opera plays in the big room next door. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，假装一切都很好，非常好。这里没发生什么不寻常的事——当歌剧在隔壁的大厅演奏时。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播和美国公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, of course, bringing you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, See No Evil, stories of people choosing to bury their heads in the sand, choosing to look at the other way. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Denying The Invisible.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，当然，带给你们关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“非礼勿视”，讲述人们选择掩耳盗铃、选择视而不见的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，否认不可见的事实。
At this point, lots of people have said that immediately after the Fukushima reactor was hit by an earthquake and tsunami, the Japanese power company TEPCO and the Japanese government were not so forthcoming with the truth. As you may heard just a few days after the nuclear accident, the head of the American Nuclear Regulatory Commission said that things were a lot worse than the Japanese power company and the government were admitting and suggested that a larger evacuation would be appropriate. The International Atomic Energy Agency later said the same thing.
目前，很多人都说，福岛核电站受到地震和海啸冲击后，日本电力公司东京电力公司和日本政府并没有那么直言不讳地告知真相。正如你们可能听到的，核事故发生仅仅几天后，美国核管理委员会负责人说情况比日本电力公司和政府承认的要糟糕得多，并建议进行更大规模的疏散。国际原子能机构后来也说了同样的话。
But as time has gone on, things have improved. The government is posting radiation counts for every Japanese city, every hour. And this week Greenpeace announced that they went out and measured radiation and the government's numbers are accurate. And the examples that you hear of Japan not providing timely information are nothing-- really nothing-- compared to the wholesale whitewashing-- the total denial of reality-- at the biggest nuclear accident before Fukushima, which of course was Chernobyl in 1986.
但随着时间的推移，情况有所改善。政府每小时发布每个日本城市的辐射值。本周绿色和平组织宣布他们去测量了辐射，政府的数字是准确的。而你听到的日本未提供及时信息的例子，与福岛之前最大的核事故——也就是1986年的切尔诺贝利——那大规模的粉饰、对现实的彻底否认相比，简直算不了什么。
Now, Chernobyl was a much, much bigger nuclear disaster than Fukushima, and much more radiation released. There's a great book, published in Russian a decade after the disaster and later translated into English, called Voices From Chernobyl. A reporter named Svetlana Alexievich interviewed hundreds of people who were there. And the stories people tell are just stunning and really take you there in a way that few interviews ever do.
切尔诺贝利是一场比福岛大得多得多的核灾难，释放的辐射也多得多。有一本好书，在灾难发生十年后以俄语出版，后来被翻译成英语，叫《切尔诺贝利的声音》。一位名叫斯维特兰娜·阿列克谢耶维奇的记者采访了数百名亲历者。人们讲述的故事令人震撼，以很少有采访能做到的方式将你带入现场。
Reading the book, you realize that not acknowledging just how dangerous the plant was and just how dangerous the situation was, you realize that that was just part of the Soviet system. It took three days for Moscow to even acknowledge that the accident at Chernobyl reactor number four had happened. The population wasn't evacuated immediately, wasn't given potassium iodide to protect themselves, wasn't warned about consuming milk produced in the region that had been contaminated.
阅读这本书，你会意识到，不去承认核电站的危险以及情况的危险性，只是苏联体制的一部分。莫斯科花了三天时间才承认切尔诺贝利四号反应堆发生了事故。居民没有被立即疏散，没有服用碘化钾保护自己，也没有被警告不要食用该地区受到污染的牛奶。
One of the men interviewed in the book, somebody who was brought in to bury radioactive plants and trees during the clean-up, says the Russian newspaper headlines in the immediate aftermath were all about triumph. "The Reactor Has Been Defeated!" "Life Goes On." "Chernobyl-- A Place of Achievement." And this man goes on to say, quote, "Just four days after the catastrophe, the red flag was already flying over the fourth reactor. It blazed forth. In a month, the radiation had devoured it. So they put up another flag. And in another month, they put up another one. I try to imagine how the soldiers felt going up on the roof to replace that flag. These were suicide missions. What would you call this? Soviet paganism? Live sacrifice?"
书中采访的一名男子，一位在清理工作中被叫去掩埋放射性植物和树木的人说，事件发生后，俄罗斯报纸的标题全都是关于胜利。“反应堆被战胜了！”“生活继续。”“切尔诺贝利——成就之地。”这个人继续说，引述，“灾难发生仅仅四天后，红旗就已经在四号反应堆上方飘扬。它耀眼夺目。一个月后，辐射吞噬了它。所以他们又竖起了一面旗。再过一个月，他们又竖起了一面。我试图想象那些爬上屋顶去更换旗帜的士兵们是什么感觉。那是自杀任务。你管这叫什么？苏联异教？活祭？”
Another thing about these interviews, they remind of something that hasn't been talked about much in coverage from Japan, and that's what radiation can do to a person. At our story meeting for our radio show this week, we were all talking about this. What can it do to you again?
这些采访的另一件事是，它们提醒人们一些在日本的报道中没怎么谈及的事情，那就是辐射会对人造成什么伤害。本周在我们广播节目的故事策划会上，我们都在谈论这个。辐射到底能对你造成什么伤害？
The most heartbreaking interview in the book is with a woman named Lyudmilla Ignatenko, whose name I'm probably mangling here. Her husband, Vasily, got dosed with about as severe a dose of radiation that somebody can get. He was a firefighter sent in the first day of the explosions at the Chernobyl reactor number four. He was sent in in his shirt sleeves, no protective equipment at all, and was in a hospital by 7:00 that night, with radiation poisoning so severe that over the next week his skin started coming off in layers. Within two weeks, he was coughing up pieces of his lungs and another organs as his body disintegrated from inside.
书中让人心碎的采访是一位名叫柳德米拉·伊格纳琴科的女性，她的名字我可能念错了。她的丈夫瓦西里受到了几乎是人所能承受的严重辐射剂量。他是切尔诺贝利四号反应堆爆炸第一天被派去的消防员。他没戴任何防护装备，只穿着衬衫就被派去了，当晚7点就在医院了，遭受了极其严重的辐射病，以至于在接下来的一周里，他的皮肤开始一层层剥落。两周内，当他的身体从内部解体时，他咳出了肺部和其他器官的碎片。
But they were newlyweds. And although it was forbidden, Lyudmilla somehow got herself into the hospital where the radiation patients were so she could be with him. Inside there, the doctors and nurses would give him shots and treat him through this transparent curtain that would shield them from radiation that was now pouring out of his body. But she went inside that curtain day after day, to sit with him.
但他们是新婚夫妇。虽然是被禁止的，但柳德米拉以某种方式潜入了辐射病人所在的医院，以便能陪在他身边。在里面，医生和护士通过这种透明的帘子给他打针和治疗，帘子能保护他们免受他体内散发出的辐射伤害。但她日复一日地走进帘子，坐在他身边。
Here's an excerpt from that interview read by an actor, Sarah Mollo-Christensen.
以下是该采访的摘录，由演员莎拉·莫洛-克里斯滕森朗读。
I go back to the hospital and there's an orange on the bedside table. A big one, and pink. He's smiling. "I got a gift. Take it." Meanwhile, the nurse is gesturing through the film that I can't eat it. It's been near him awhile, so not only can you not eat it, you shouldn't even touch it. "Come on, eat it," he says. "You like oranges." I take the orange in my hand. Meanwhile, he shuts his eyes and goes to sleep. They were always giving him shots to put him to sleep. The nurse is looking at me in horror.
我回到医院，床头柜上放着一个橘子。一个大的，粉红色的。他在笑。“我收到了礼物。拿去吧。”同时，护士隔着薄膜向我打手势，示意我不能吃。它在他旁边待了一会儿，所以不仅不能吃，甚至连碰都不应该碰。“来吧，吃吧，”他说。“你喜欢橘子。”我手里拿着橘子。同时，他闭上眼睛睡着了。他们总是给他打针让他睡觉。护士惊恐地看着我。
And me? I'm ready to do whatever it takes so that he doesn't think about death. And about the fact that his death is horrible, that I'm afraid of him. There's a fragment of some conversation, I'm remembering it. Someone is saying, "You have to understand, this is not your husband anymore, not a beloved person, but a radioactive object with a strong density of poisoning. You're not suicidal. Get ahold of yourself." And I'm like someone who's lost her mind. "But I love him! I love him!" He's sleeping, and I'm whispering, "I love you." Walking in the hospital courtyard, "I love you." Carrying his sanitary tray, "I love you."
而我呢？我准备做任何事，这样他就不会去想死亡。不去想死亡是恐怖的，不去想我害怕他。我记得一段对话的片段。有人说，“你要明白，这不是你的丈夫了，不是一个亲爱的人，而是一个具有高浓度毒性的放射性物体。你不是想自杀。振作起来。”我就像个疯了的人。“但我爱他！我爱他！”他在睡觉，我低声说，“我爱你。”走在医院的院子里，“我爱你。”搬着他的卫生盘，“我爱你。”
I remembered how we used to live at home. He only fell asleep at night after he'd taken my hand. That was a habit of his-- to hold my hand while he slept. All night. So in the hospital, I take his hand and don't let go.
我记得我们在家时是怎么生活的。他只有在拉着我的手之后才会入睡。这是他的习惯——睡觉时握着我的手。整晚。所以在医院里，我握着他的手，再也不松开。
Some of the interviews in this book deal a lot on the see no evil aspect of what happened at Chernobyl-- how the government and even the people on the ground dealing with the emergency would turn a blind eye to the truth of what they were dealing with, because the Soviet system just wasn't set up to handle the truth. And so for most people in the middle of the crisis, at many points it was just much easier to look the other way.
这本书中的一些采访很大程度上涉及了切尔诺贝利事件中“非礼勿视”的一面——政府甚至在现场处理紧急情况的人如何对他们所面对的真相视而不见，因为苏联体制根本无法处理真相。因此，对于危机中的大多数人来说，在许多时刻，转过头去要容易得多。
We have one more reading from the book, a longer reading from an interview with Zoya Danilovna Bruk, who was environmental inspector in the region.
我们要朗读书中最后一段，摘自对佐雅·丹尼洛芙娜·布鲁克的采访，她是该地区的环保检查员，这是一段较长的朗读。
I worked at the inspection center for environmental defense. We were waiting for some kind of instructions, but we didn't receive any. There were very few professionals on our staff, especially among the directors. They were retired colonels, former party workers, retirees, or other undesirables. If you messed up somewhere else, they'd send you to us. Then you'd sit there shuffling papers. At that time, my notions of nuclear power stations were utterly idyllic. At school and at the university, we'd been taught that this was a magical factory that made energy out of nothing, where people in white robes sat and pushed buttons.
我在环境保护检查中心工作。我们在等待某种指示，但没有收到任何指示。我们的员工中专业人士很少，尤其是在领导层中。他们是退休的上校、前党务工作者、退休人员或其他不受欢迎的人。如果你在别处搞砸了，他们就会把你送到我们这儿来。然后你就坐在那儿整理文件。那时，我对核电站的概念是极其理想化的。在学校和大学里，我们被教导说这是一个魔术工厂，能凭空创造能源，人们身穿白袍，坐在那儿按按钮。
Chernobyl blew up when we weren't prepared. And also, there wasn't any information. There were rumors-- someone read in some paper, someone heard, someone said. We went around the region collecting samples of water, earth, and taking them to Minsk. Our assistants were grumbling, "We're carrying hotcakes." We had no defense, no special clothing. You'd be sitting in the front seat and behind you there were samples just glowing.
切尔诺贝利爆炸时，我们毫无准备。而且，没有任何信息。只有谣言——某人在某张报纸上读到，某人听到，某人说。我们四处收集水、土样本，带到明斯克。我们的助手抱怨说：“我们运送的是‘热蛋糕’（指放射性样本）。”我们没有任何防护，没有防护服。你坐在前座，身后是正在发光的样本。
And by this point, they started sending us out on inspections. I was sent to a timber processing plant. They weren't receiving any less timber. The plan hadn't been altered, so they kept to it. I turned on my instrument at the warehouse and it started going nuts. The boards were OK. But if I turned it on near the brooms, it went off the chart. "Where are the brooms from?" "Krasnopol." And Krasnopol, as it later turned out, was the most contaminated place in the Mogilev region. "We have one shipment left. The others went out already." And how are you going to find them in all the towns they were sent to?
到了这个时候，他们开始派我们去视察。我被派往一家木材加工厂。他们收到的木材一点没少。计划没有改变，所以他们坚持执行。我在仓库里打开仪器，它开始疯了一样乱响。木板还可以。但如果我在扫帚附近打开它，读数就爆表了。“扫帚是哪来的？”“克拉斯诺波尔。”克拉斯诺波尔，后来发现，是莫吉廖夫地区污染最严重的地方。“我们只剩下一批货了。其他的已经发出去了。”你怎么能在他们发送到的所有城镇里找到它们呢？
They had protocols written up for burying radioactive earth. We buried earth in earth-- such a strange human activity.
他们制定了掩埋放射性土壤的规程。我们把土埋在土里——真是奇怪的人类活动。
According to the instructions, we were supposed to conduct a geological survey before burying anything, to determine that there was no groundwater within four to six meters of the burial site and that the depth of the pit wasn't very great. And also that the walls and bottoms of the pit be lined with polyethylene film. That's what the instructions said. In real life it was, of course, different. As always. There was no geological survey. They'd point their fingers and say, "Dig here." The excavator digs. "How deep did you go" "Who the hell knows? I stopped when I hit water." They were digging right into the water.
根据说明书，我们在掩埋任何东西之前都应该进行地质勘探，以确定掩埋点四到六米内没有地下水，并且坑的深度不是很大。而且坑壁和坑底要铺上聚乙烯薄膜。这是说明书上写的。现实生活中，当然不同。一如既往。没有地质勘探。他们指着指头说：“在这儿挖。”挖掘机开挖。“挖多深？”“鬼知道？碰到水我就停了。”他们直接挖到了水里。
My longest assignment was in the Krasnopolsk region, which was the worst. In order to keep the radionuclides from washing off the fields into the rivers, we needed to follow the instructions again. You had to plow double furrows, leave a gap, and then again put in double furrows, and so on, with the same intervals. According to the instructions, the tractors laying down the furrows were supposed to have driver's cabins that were hermetically sealed and protected. I saw the tractor. And the cabin was indeed hermetically sealed. But the tractor was sitting there, and the driver was lying on the grass, taking a break. "Are you crazy? Haven't you been warned?" "But I put my sweatshirt over my head," he says.
我分配时间最长的地方是克拉斯诺波尔地区，那是情况最糟糕的。为了防止放射性核素从田地冲进河流，我们需要再次遵循指示。你必须犁出双沟，留出间隔，然后再犁出双沟，以此类推，间隔保持一致。根据指示，挖掘沟渠的拖拉机驾驶室应该是密封并受保护的。我看到了那台拖拉机。驾驶室确实是密封的。但拖拉机停在那儿，司机躺在草地上休息。“你疯了吗？没警告过你吗？”他说，“但我把运动衫套在头上了。”
It's such a beautiful land out there. The old forests are still there-- ancient forests, the winding little steams, the color of tea and clear as day, green grass. People calling to each other through the forest. For them it was so natural, like waking up in the morning and walking out into your garden. And you're standing there knowing it's all been poisoned.
那里是一片如此美丽的土地。古老的森林依然存在——原始森林，蜿蜒的小溪，茶色清晰见底，绿色的草地。人们在森林中互相呼唤。对他们来说，这太自然了，就像早上醒来走进花园一样。而你站在那里，知道这一切都被毒害了。
We ran into an old lady. "Children, tell me, can I drink milk from my cow?" We looked down at the ground, we have our orders-- collect data, but don't interact with the locals. Finally, the driver speaks up. "Grandma, how old are you? " "Oh, more than 80. Maybe more than that. My documents got burned during the war." "Then drink all you want."
我们遇到了一位老太太。“孩子们，告诉我，我可以喝我家奶牛的奶吗？”我们低头看着地面，我们有命令——收集数据，但不要与当地人接触。最后，司机开口了。“奶奶，你多大了？”“哦，80多岁了。可能更多。我的证件在战争期间被烧毁了。”“那就喝个够吧。”
I feel worst of all for the people in the villages. They couldn't understand what had happened. They wanted to believe scientists or any educated person, like they would a priest. But they were told, "Everything's fine. There's nothing to fear. Just wash your hands before eating."
我最为村里的人感到难过。他们无法理解发生了什么。他们想相信科学家或任何受过教育的人，就像他们信任牧师一样。但他们被告知：“一切都很好。没什么可害怕的。吃东西前洗手就行了。”
People turned out to be worse than I thought. And me, too. I'm also worse. Now I know this about myself. Of course, I admit this, and for me that's already important.
结果人们比我想象的还要糟糕。我也是。我也更糟。现在我了解了自己的这一点。当然，我承认这一点，对我来说这已经很重要了。
But, again, an example. In one kolkhoz there are, say, five villages. Three are "clean," two are "dirty." Between them there are maybe two or three kilometers. Now, the "clean" village is building a livestock complex, and they need to get some clean feed. Where will they get it? The wind blows the radioactive dust from one field to the next. It's all one land. In order to build the complex, they need some papers signed. And the commission that signs them, I'm on that commission.
但是，再举个例子。在一个集体农庄里，比如有五个村庄。三个是“干净”的，两个是“肮脏”的。它们之间可能只有两三公里。现在，“干净”的村庄正在建设一个牲畜综合体，他们需要获得一些干净的饲料。他们从哪儿弄？风把放射性尘埃从一个田地吹到另一个田地。这全是同一片土地。为了建造这个综合体，他们需要签署一些文件。而签署这些文件的委员会，我就是委员之一。
Everyone knows we can't sign those papers. It's a crime. But in the end, I found a justification for myself, just like everyone else. I thought, the problem of clean feed is not a problem for an environmental inspector. Everyone found a justification for themselves-- an explanation. And basically, I found out that the frightening things in life happen quietly and naturally.
每个人都知道我们不能签署那些文件。这是犯罪。但最后，我和其他人一样，为自己找到了理由。我想，干净饲料的问题不是环保检查员的问题。每个人都为自己找到了理由——一种解释。基本上，我发现生活中那些可怕的事情是悄悄地、自然地发生的。
Kelly Coffield Park, reading an interview with an environmental inspector from the area near Chernobyl at the time the nuclear accident there. It's an excerpt from this book of unusually vivid interviews called Voices From Chernobyl , by reporter Svetlana Alexievich and translated by Keith Gessin.
凯莉·考菲尔德·帕克朗读了一段对切尔诺贝利附近地区环保检查员的采访，内容发生在核事故当时。这是斯维特兰娜·阿列克谢耶维奇的记者所著、凯斯·格辛翻译的访谈录《切尔诺贝利的声音》中的摘录，这些采访异常生动。
[MUSIC - "A HARD RAIN'S A GONNA FALL" BY LEON RUSSELL]
[音乐 - 莱昂·拉塞尔的《一场大雨将至》]
Act Three, "I Worked At The Kennedy Center And All I Got Was This Lousy T-Shirt." David Kestenbaum has the story of one man's-- this is actually his cousin that this story is about-- one man's search for evil, evil-- I said evil-- in a place that you wouldn't expect.
第三幕，“我在肯尼迪中心工作，却只得到了这件烂T恤。” 大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆讲述了一个男人的故事——这实际上是他表弟的故事——关于一个人在预想不到的地方寻找邪恶的故事。我说了，是邪恶。
If the Obamas want to go out for a theater date or to the ballet or to hear Yo-Yo Ma, there is a place that has a special presidential box for them to sit in-- the Kennedy Center for the Performing Arts in Washington DC. Plush seats, soaring ceilings, all that stuff. But when my cousin Dan Weiss worked there in the 1970s, he spent a lot of time in the basement. He was a smart, idealistic kid, still in college. The basement is where the stockroom was for the gift shops upstairs.
如果奥巴马一家想去剧院约会、看芭蕾舞或听马友友演奏，有一个地方有专门的总统包厢给他们坐——华盛顿特区的肯尼迪表演艺术中心。豪华的座位，高耸的天花板，所有那些东西。但当我的表弟丹·韦斯在1970年代在那里工作时，他花了很多时间在地下室。他是个聪明、理想主义的孩子，还在上大学。地下室是楼上礼品店的仓库。
When I started, I was basically a stock clerk. I would stock the gift shops each day with merchandise. And I ran up and down the stairs all day long-- up and down, up and down, up and down.
刚开始的时候，我基本上是个库存管理员。我每天用商品给礼品店补货。我整天跑上跑下——上上下下，上上下下。
That's a skill that was in demand at the gift shops, because the gift shops were staffed by volunteers, a lot of them retired. 300 volunteers.
那是一项在礼品店很受欢迎的技能，因为礼品店的工作人员都是志愿者，很多是退休人员。共有300名志愿者。
All of our sales people were well-intentioned volunteers. Many of them simply wanted to be in the Kennedy Center to support the mission.
我们所有的销售人员都是心地善良的志愿者。他们很多人只是想在肯尼迪中心支持其使命。
So these are retired people who love the theater, or love opera, or love symphonies.
所以这些都是热爱戏剧、热爱歌剧或热爱交响乐的退休人员。
That's right. I would suspect in my experience that not a single one of them had had a retail job before they took this job.
没错。根据我的经验，我怀疑他们中没有一个人在做这份工作之前从事过零售工作。
The gift shops-- there were two-- were run kind of like lemonade stands. They sold t-shirts, books, commemorative spoons, but no cash registers, no receipts, just a little cash box. The volunteers would come in whenever their schedules allowed. The Kennedy Center had just opened, and at the beginning, everything seemed sort of charmed. There weren't a lot of a rules. For instance, when Dan found a stray cat meowing and hungry, he kept it in the stock room with all the merchandise. The cat got kind of famous.
礼品店——总共有两家——运营得有点像柠檬水摊。他们卖T恤、书、纪念勺子，但没有收银机，没有收据，只有一个小现金盒。志愿者们在日程允许的情况下随时来工作。肯尼迪中心刚开业，起初，一切似乎都很顺利。没什么规矩。例如，当丹发现一只流浪猫在喵喵叫而且饿了的时候，他把它养在放满所有商品的仓库里。这只猫变得很有名。
He lived down there and had the parade of visitors. Leonard Bernstein went in to pet him, and Mikhail Baryshnikov.
它住在下面，有一群访客。伦纳德·伯恩斯坦进去抚摸过它，米哈伊尔·巴里什尼科夫也摸过。
The gift shops, I should explain, were not a small operation. They sold $400,000 worth of stuff a year. And while no one liked to talk about it, in these lovely gift shops, in this lovely building where the National Symphony played, something was seriously wrong.
我应该解释一下，礼品店的业务规模并不小。他们每年销售价值40万美元的东西。虽然没人喜欢谈论这件事，但在这些可爱的礼品店里，在这个国家交响乐团演奏的可爱建筑里，出了一些严重的问题。
The gift shop operation was clearly underperforming. There wasn't very much money making it to the bank, given all the merchandise that we were selling. And no one really understood why that was happening.
礼品店的运营表现明显欠佳。考虑到我们售出的所有商品，存入银行的钱并不多。没人真正明白为什么会发生这种情况。
The nice man running the gift shop at the time got fired. And Dan suddenly got a big promotion. At age 21, he became manager of gift shops at the Kennedy Center for the Performing Arts. His new job-- figure out where the money was disappearing to. Dan didn't have any business training. He'd majored in art history and psychology. Aside from a stint in high school at an ice cream parlor, this was his first real job, his first time seeing how business worked. But he's a pretty driven guy. And if you give him a task, he's going to sink his teeth in. And the first thing he did was a bit of math.
当时运营礼品店的好心人被解雇了。丹突然获得了大升职。21岁时，他成为了肯尼迪表演艺术中心礼品店的经理。他的新任务——找出钱消失到哪里去了。丹没有任何商业培训。他主修艺术史和心理学。除了高中时在一家冰淇淋店打过工，这是他的第一份真正工作，他第一次看到商业是如何运作的。但他是个很有干劲的人。如果给他任务，他会咬住不放。他做的第一件事就是做了一些数学计算。
So I tried to figure that out-- how much money were we losing, how much merchandise were we losing? And in the retail sales business, they use a term called shrinkage. And that is the percentage of overall sales that you might be losing somehow-- merchandise, cash, who knows? And it was almost 40% when I took the job initially. That means that $0.40 on every dollar that was supposed to go into the bank-- we weren't sure where it was going, but it wasn't going into the bank.
所以我试图弄清楚——我们损失了多少钱，我们损失了多少商品？在零售业，他们使用一个术语叫“损耗”（shrinkage）。也就是你可能以某种方式损失的总销售额百分比——商品、现金，谁知道呢？我刚接手这份工作时，几乎达到40%。这意味着每一美元里本该进入银行的40美分——我们不确定它们流向了哪里，但它们没进银行。
And what's a typical number out there in the world for small businesses?
那么小企业的正常数字是多少？
Back in the day when I did this work in the 1970s, a big shrinkage number at Macy's or at some other store might be, probably 3%.
在我1970年代做这项工作时，梅西百货或其他一些商店的大型损耗数字可能大概是3%。
And you were 40%.
而你们是40%。
We were big time. We were 40%.
我们是大玩家。我们是40%。
Somewhere there had to be a thief. Dan ran through the entire gift shop operation methodically, obsessively. And began to suspect one guy-- a younger guy in his 20s, one of the other paid employees who helped run the place. The guy's job was to transfer the money from the cash box to the safe at closing time.
某个地方肯定有个小偷。丹有条不紊、近乎强迫症地运行了整个礼品店的运营。并开始怀疑一个人——一个20多岁的年轻人，是帮助运营这里的其他领薪员工之一。那人的工作是在下班时将钱从现金盒转移到保险柜。
Dan's next move? Well, if you're the manager of a gift shop, stealing from the cash box is kind of a strange-sized problem to have. You don't call the FBI. Do you call the security guards? Do you call the police? It turns out, if you work at the Kennedy Center, there is someone special you call.
丹的下一步举动？好吧，如果你是一家礼品店的经理，从现金盒里偷钱是一个相当奇怪的问题。你不打给FBI。你打给保安吗？你打给警察吗？事实证明，如果你在肯尼迪中心工作，有一个特殊的人你可以打给。
I had to engage the United States Park Police detective agents, who oversaw the Kennedy Center. Special investigative arm of the United States Park Service.
我不得不联系负责监督肯尼迪中心的美国公园警察侦探人员。美国国家公园管理局的特殊调查部门。
Who knew they had one?
谁知道他们有这个部门？
I didn't until that began.
直到那时开始之前我也不知道。
The Park Service assigned Dan a detective.
公园管理局给丹分配了一名侦探。
His name was Loveless. And I thought what a great name for a detective. He was actually quite charming.
他的名字叫洛夫莱斯（Loveless，意为无爱）。我想这对侦探来说是个多好的名字。他实际上相当迷人。
Detective Loveless had actually seen a lot in his time. And he was amused by the idea of a thief at a place known for opera, musicals, and ballet. But he gave the job his full attention. Told Dan, if you want to catch this guy we're going to have to plan out a sting operation. So after work one day, detective Loveless picked up Dan in an unmarked car and drove to a secret location.
洛夫莱斯侦探在他那个时代见识过很多事。他对在一个以歌剧、音乐剧和芭蕾舞而闻名的地方出现小偷这个想法感到好笑。但他全神贯注于这份工作。告诉丹，如果你想抓住这家伙，我们必须计划一次钓鱼行动。所以有一天下班后，洛夫莱斯侦探开着一辆无标志汽车接上丹，开车去了一个秘密地点。
Well, his favorite place to meet-- which was, I suppose if you're a policeman, a secret place, but it didn't seem so to me-- was he would pick me up on the street in Washington and drive over Memorial Bridge. And at the traffic circle on the other side of Memorial Bridge, right in front of Arlington Cemetery-- which is a highway-- he would drive up the curb and park his car right there, smack on the grass in the middle of the traffic circle on Memorial Bridge. And we would spend 20 minutes or a half an hour sitting there, probably seen by 25,000 people who drove by, in our secret place. But I guess he assumed if you're right out in the middle of everything, nobody notices you.
嗯，他最喜欢见面的地方——我想如果你是警察，这是一个秘密地方，但对我来说似乎不是——他会在华盛顿街头接我，开车过纪念大桥。在纪念大桥另一头的交通环岛，就在阿灵顿国家公墓前面——那是一条高速公路——他会把车开上路缘，直接停在那儿，停在纪念大桥交通环岛中间的草地上。我们会花20分钟或半小时坐在那里，可能被路过的25000人看到，就在我们的秘密地点。但我猜他认为如果你就处在所有事物的中心，没人会注意到你。
One Friday night, they set the trap. Dan walks as nonchalantly as possible into the Kennedy Center gift shop, says hi to the volunteers like nothing's up at all, and puts some marked bills into the cash box. Then he walks outside to rejoin Detective Loveless, who's chosen the most cliched spot for the stakeout-- in the bushes. They hide in the bushes, on the other side of the road and peer across into the gift shop with binoculars.
一个周五晚上，他们设下了陷阱。丹尽可能漫不经心地走进肯尼迪中心礼品店，像什么事都没发生一样和志愿者打招呼，并把一些标记过的钞票放进现金盒。然后他走出去与洛夫莱斯侦探汇合，侦探选择了监视最老套的地点——灌木丛中。他们躲在马路对面的灌木丛里，用双筒望远镜盯着礼品店。
I should tell you it was February and cold. It may have been the coldest day in the history of Washington. And there we were outside, shivering in the bushes, and he's looking through the binoculars. And he would tell me, "Somebody's coming to the gift shop. Let me get you to take a look at this. Tell me who this is. Who is this? Is this our guy? Is this our guy?" And he would hand me the binoculars. And I would look and I'd say, "No, that's not our guy. That's an 85-year-old woman, who's selling spoons to a customer." And he'd say, "All right. Just checking." And that's how it would go. Every time someone went near the gift shop, he would pass me the binoculars.
我应该告诉你当时是二月，天气很冷。那可能是华盛顿历史上最冷的一天。我们就在外面，在灌木丛中颤抖，他透过双筒望远镜往里看。他会告诉我，“有人来礼品店了。让我拿给你看看。告诉我这是谁。这是谁？是我们要找的那个人吗？是我们的家伙吗？”他会把望远镜递给我。我会看，然后说，“不，不是我们的家伙。那是位85岁的老太太，正在卖勺子给顾客。”他说，“好吧。只是确认一下。”事情就是这样。每次有人靠近礼品店，他就会把望远镜递给我。
And then at just about the exact time, the staff member showed up to close up the cash register. And he got very excited. He said, "He's here. He's here. Let's go."
然后在精确的时间点，工作人员出现准备清算收银机。他变得非常兴奋。他说，“他来了。他来了。我们走。”
They intercept the guy on the way to his car. And find, yes, marked bills in his pocket. They put the guy in handcuffs and arrest him.
他们在去停车场的路上拦住了那个人。发现他口袋里确实有标记过的钞票。他们给他戴上手铐并逮捕了他。
And so, you might think, case closed. Right? But the amount of money they found on the thief, it wasn't that much. $60, just $60. In fact, when the case goes before a judge, the judge basically throws it out. All of which meant the problem Dan faced was much bigger. Remember, the amount of revenue they were missing each year was over $150,000.
所以，你可能认为案子结了。对吧？但他们在小偷身上发现的钱金额并没有那么多。60美元，只有60美元。事实上，当案子提交给法官时，法官基本上驳回了它。所有这些意味着丹面临的问题要大得多。记住，他们每年缺失的营收超过15万美元。
Dan, though, had another plan of attack-- a much more ordinary one. Paperwork. If the gift shop had been run like a lemonade stand, now he wants it to run like a lemonade factory. Dan sets up an inventory system. He posts price lists in the gift shop-- hats cost this much, t-shirts this much. Tells the retirees volunteering in the gift shop, "When you sell something, write it down." In other words, he basically reinvents on his own what any normal retail business would call record-keeping.
然而，丹还有另一个攻击计划——一个普通得多的计划。文书工作。如果礼品店一直像柠檬水摊一样运营，现在他希望它像柠檬水工厂一样运营。丹建立了一个库存系统。他在礼品店贴出价格表——帽子卖多少钱，T恤卖多少钱。告诉礼品店的退休志愿者，“当你卖出东西时，把它记下来。”换句话说，他基本上凭自己的力量重塑了任何正规零售企业都会称之为记录保存的东西。
And lo and behold, the leaking stops. The mysterious losses-- that 40% shrinkage-- began to steadily shrink. He got into Macy's territory, down to single digits. At the gift shop, Dan was a hero.
结果显而易见，漏洞堵住了。那些神秘的损失——那40%的损耗——开始稳步下降。他进入了梅西百货的领地，降到了个位数。在礼品店，丹成了英雄。
But his victory meant something kind of unsettling. It meant the problem hadn't been a thief. It was lots of thieves. In fact, as best as Dan could figure in that sea of 300 volunteers, those elderly art lovers, a bunch of them were taking stuff. And the paid staff who worked in other parts of building, they were grabbing stuff too.
但他的胜利意味着一些令人不安的事。这意味着问题不是一个小偷。是有很多小偷。事实上，正如丹在300名志愿者中能推断出的那样，那些上了年纪的艺术爱好者，他们中很多人在拿东西。而在大楼其他地方工作的领薪员工也在拿东西。
And people would walk by and pet the cat, and see merchandise and pick it up, because it was just stuff on a table, that people thought it was OK.
人们会路过，摸摸猫，看到商品就把它捡起来，因为那只是桌子上的东西，人们认为没关系。
And people weren't just grabbing t-shirts. Some had been taking cash-- mostly small amounts, like a cab fare home. After all, they'd just worked three hours for free. It's just a few dollars. What's the harm? But still, they put their hands in the cash box, took some bills out, and put the money in their pockets.
而且人们不仅在拿T恤。有些人一直在拿现金——大多是小额，比如回家的出租车费。毕竟，他们才刚刚免费工作了三小时。只有几块钱。有什么害处？但不管怎样，他们还是把手伸进现金盒，掏出一些钞票，放进兜里。
That's stealing. They were all stealing.
那是偷窃。他们都在偷窃。
There were retired volunteers there taking money out of the cash box?
那里有退休志愿者从现金盒里拿钱？
There were some volunteers who were taking money. There were some young employees who were taking money. There were lots of people who were taking merchandise, at every level. People were all stealing from this wonderful, uplifting organization because they could. Because it was easy and it was available.
有一些志愿者在拿钱。有一些年轻员工在拿钱。有很多人在拿商品，在各个层面。人们都在从这个美好、令人振奋的组织中偷东西，因为他们能这么做。因为这很容易，而且唾手可得。
If this population, these people, well-meaning, community-minded, classical music fans-- if some of them were stealing, it meant anyone would. For Dan, that was a sad thing.
如果这个群体，这些人，心地善良、具有社区意识、古典音乐迷——如果他们中有些人都在偷窃，这意味着任何人都会。对丹来说，那是一件悲伤的事。
And I guess that's the lesson I learned in 1979. We are going to take things from each other if we have a chance. I never understood that. It didn't feel OK to me then. It doesn't feel OK to me now. And it wasn't a terrifically optimistic lesson, that many people need there to be controls around them, for them to do the right thing. And if there aren't any controls around or any supervision, they may not do the right thing.
我想这就是我在1979年学到的教训。如果有机会，我们会互相占便宜。我从未理解过这一点。当时我觉得这不对劲。现在也觉得不对劲。这不是一个非常乐观的教训，许多人需要周围有控制措施，才能去做正确的事。如果没有控制或监督，他们可能就不会做正确的事。
Fresh out of college, working in a place where fancy people dress up every night, Dan discovered that not so nice truth that we all know but prefer not to think about-- that we set up security cameras, we put locks on doors, we have paperwork and passwords. And those things aren't there just for criminals. They're there, at the saying goes, to keep honest people honest.
刚走出大学，在一个时髦的人每晚盛装打扮的地方工作，丹发现了我们都知道却宁愿不去想的那个不太美好的真相——我们安装安全摄像头，给门加锁，我们有文书工作和密码。而这些东西不仅是为了对付罪犯。正如谚语所说，它们是为了保持正直的人正直。
David Kestenbaum is part of the Planet Money team. You can hear him on their free podcast at npr.org/money.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是“Planet Money”团队的一员。你可以在npr.org/money上通过他们的免费播客收听他的节目。
[MUSIC - "SEE NO EVIL", TELEVISION]
[音乐 - 《非礼勿视》，Television乐队]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semian, and Alissa Shipp. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our West Coast producer.
好了，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼希、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米安和阿丽莎·希普制作。赛斯·林德是我们的制片经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。简·伯曼作为我们的西海岸制片人替补。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatea, who explains his boyhood dream to someday work at a radio station this way.
《美国生活》由美国公共广播国际公司发行。WBEZ的管理层监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他这样解释自己童年时梦想有朝一日在广播电台工作的愿望。
At school and at the university, we'd been taught that this was a magical factory, where people in white robes sat and pushed buttons.
在学校和大学里，我们被教导说这是一个魔术工厂，人们身穿白袍，坐在那儿按按钮。
And indeed, that's what it's like. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
事实确实如此，就是这样。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。美国公共广播国际公司。